Au début, je ne savais pas si je devais me prendre la Wii U.
Et puis, je me suis souvenu de cette promesse que je m'étais faîte lorsque j'avais 11 ans :
"Quand je serais grand,
je m'acheterais toutes les consoles, le jour de leur sortie."
Et puis, bah...
(musique : Zelda, Ouverture d'un coffre)
C'est la nouvelle console de salon de Nintendo
qui a la particularité d'avoir une manette, avec un écran tactile.
Bon, et c'est vrai que, jouer, sur une console de salon, qui a un écran dans sa manette,
au début, on peut trouver ça un peu bizarre.
Probablement le meilleur téléviseur du marché.
Seulement 31 millimètres d'épaisseur,
116 centimètres de diagonale,
une définition full HD de 1920 par 1080 pixels,
des images époustouflantes, tout ça...
pour jouer sur un écran de 6 pouces.
Bon, et après avoir joué à plein de jeu,
le gamepad, c'est quand même vachement bien.
Tu peux... Tu peux faire des courses,
envoyer des shurikens, tout ça...
Pour l'instant, on ne peut jouer qu'avec un seul gamepad par console.
Comme on peut voir sur la boite du jeu "Nintendo Land".
Donc quand tu joues avec des potes,
on peut assister à ce que j'appelle :
Tu veux jouer la Wii U ?
D'accord.
Tu veux quelle manette ?
Mmh...
Laisse moi peser le pour et le contre...
D'un côté, une manette totalement neuve avec un écran tactile dessus.
De l'autre une manette dégeulasse qui date de 6 ans.
Non ! Elle est à moi !
C'est quand même original comme concept :
Un des joueurs,
a une manette différente,
avec son propre écran.
Enfin, limite, il ne serait pas dans la même pièce, ce serais pareil, quoi...
Non, mais, aller les mecs, moi je veux jou...
Non ! Tu va jouer dans la chambre !
Tu as voulu le gamepad ! Et maintenant tu assumes ! Ok !
Non, mais, moi juste jouer avec vous...
Dans la chambre !
Et avec le sourire s'il te plait.
Voilà ! Un sourire Nintendo. C'est bien.
Le premier truc qui m'a choqué avec cette manette,
bah c'est... la taille, hein...
Regardez ça, on dirait...
Oui c'est pour qui le demi ?
It's me !
Le monsieur avec la moustache. C'est partit.
J'espère que Nintendo va s'arrêter là, hein...
Après le succès de la Wii U.
Voici :
"La Wii Y"
Ah ! J'ai une crampe au bras. Ah, m*rde. Ah !
D'ailleurs en plus de l'écran tactile,
ils ont ajouté une caméra dans la manette,
qui permet notamment
de vous filmer, pendant que vous jouez.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà vu votre tête, lorsque vous jouez à un jeu vidéo ?
JE VEUX GAGNER !!
JE VEUX GAGNER !
Bon, par contre, une fois que tu as compris le truc, bah tu...
tu joues différemment, quoi.
*Clin d'œil*
Bon, la caméra sert aussi à autre chose :
On peut se prendre en photo, pour faire son propre Mii.
Regardez, ça c'est mon Mii.
J'ai trouvé une astuce pour mettre d'autres visages.
(roulement de tambours)
Eh ! C'est pas trop mal, hein...
Et pour finir, ma conclusion sur la Wii U :
C'est bien !
Je suis un mec plutôt concis dans la vie, hein... J'aime bien tu sais quand c'est...
Ah, au faîte, je vous avais dit un truc dans mon avant-dernière vidéo :
"Ah, ah, oui j'ai une petite surprise pour vous,
sur mon téléphone."
Je viens de sortir une application, sur Iphone et Android.
C'est pour voir mes vidéos,
être prévenu lorsqu'il y en a une nouvelle qui sort,
on peut jouer avec mes vidéos.
(charge une arme à feu)
(tire)
Et il y a le Cyprigram,
c'est pour faire des photos comme sur Instagram
Mais... Version euh...
Moi.
Voilà, dans les grandes lignes..
Téléchargez la ! Elle est gratuite !
C'est pas chère quoi.
À bientôt !
Sous-titres : LeLinkDuFutur                    Vérification : Alexandre Man